but long let me pitch long lost family
dude
it's basically um
you know you won't be for long
no if it's on tls tlc has got some great
shows so it's like you know either it's
either you know somebody was given up
for adoption either the mom or dad
looking for their son
or vice versa
who who is through adoption
like when a when parents give their kid
away or a mother gives their kid away at
birth
and then you know
40 years down the road you know the mom
goes i'm trying to look for my kid did
they find the kid for them and there's
they reunite right oh i'm in yeah yeah
i'm in it makes me cry right but
let me ask you something
um
if if you were
if you because there was one where some
guy found out his mom was still homeless
oh yeah would you
i i don't want to go down this line
i'm just saying that if if i see if i
just just hear my i'm going to go a
different direction right i like the
first one
right i will in a second okay
but i think this will clear it up um
if i was like giving up for adoption and
i looked for and my parents were
rockefellers
i'd be like ewik
yeah
mommy right right but it's like if the
reverse happened would you would you
i don't know
excited
so if you're looking to find your mom
you find out your mom's homeless yeah
i mean i would definitely try to help
her yeah i know but there's what we
don't know like what you know because
you're a guy who's only looking at what
he can get from people whoa whoa
get the range rover bobby
get that
range rover and this time i only want
one door on it for you and you only
yeah maybe you're right you know what i
i think you know you're right i would be
excited
because i could give them a sandwich and
they'd be happy and stuff yeah yeah yeah
that'd be cool
but this is like i don't want this is
what i think the constant calling like
it's mom again
you know you think she has a phone
there's no call
okay all right
wow
maybe i am shallow you think i'm shallow
i'm not even yeah sometimes in that way
i am yeah yeah
i love like if you had said something
else like i'm just afraid that she's
gonna continually hit me up for like
like let's say
she had uh a drug problem right i'd be
afraid to you know i don't wanna be the
enabler she's always gonna wanna hit me
up and then i'm always going to want to
give you money that's a long
what i was thinking that was not
what if i have to kill it
right could you feel it right
that thought where you're a month in and
then all of a sudden she's just like you
got any more aluminum foil you're like
you didn't make any food what are you
doing with that
and she made a hat or whatever yeah my
point is is that
you you you're they're i feel like
they're gonna hit you up a lot and it's
gonna become like a codependent
relationship it just seems like more um
just added problems almost
what argue
okay you just that's the assumption that
all homeless people become you know
homeless because of one thing but it
could be many things that's true we live
in a tough tough country we live in a
tough society i saw a homeless guy
recently going up laurel
and he had a sign at the bottom he had
his instagram handle on it
and i wanted to hate but i was like
honestly why not
why not yeah yeah and i don't remember
it let's shout them out no no no this
was over this was like three months ago
my biggest thought was like what if he
doesn't follow you back
devastating that would well then yeah
you're right yeah that's what he get
that's how he gets because he's really
obsessed with american idol so what he
does is like
last week
he was just on the couch just going
through every single contestant system
see if they follow him and then being
like dude i love you you did so great if
you need tips hit me back up and i'm
like bobby what tips are you going to
give them no that's not true that's a
lie and then if they
i said i'm not done and then if they
don't follow him back